was something he was here in sega we had  wonderful time i know exactly how nice  person he is  and uh  this applies to to all the indian  players that i have met  by the way ganguly also very good friend  he was also in sega already  also 2012 yes so i have very very good  connections  with vishy i was always very close we  have worked with vishy  like in in 2016  uh 2016 pardon me i mean 99 to 60. i  mean 96  96 yeah i'm already confused with all  these dates i started working when i was  16 years old with vidvishy then you  remember once before a madrid tournament  in 98 we gathered vichy was kind enough  to invite us to his his place and we  were there all together yeah  and by the way black has designed yeah  yeah  check  and and black resigned  because king e5 runs into ah pardon  making if i come into looking a check